fue el último contingente de soldados
franceses de la operación barcán el
lunes tomaron sus pertenencias y se
marcharon tras las crecientes tensiones
con la junta gobernante la operación de
9 años dejan variado legado pero por
ahora los soldados que parten se
concentran en el peligroso viaje que
tienen por delante tienen solo unos días
para mover cientos de piezas de equipos
y llevarlas a la base francesa en níger
la de gao debe ser entregada al ejército
malience Así que se van en unas horas
dejamos este lugar de operaciones en
unas horas
Cómo se siente
Cómo puede Cómo podría decirlo está
completo nuestra misión aquí se ha
completado es muy importante que nos
vayamos todos juntos y con buena salud
con los años la influencia del grupo
estado islámico se ha expandido en el
lado malience de la frontera con níger
el 7 de agosto 42 soldados malienses
murieron en un ataque yihadista en tesis
mientras se retiran los soldados
franceses prefieren evitar hablar de
política el sentimiento de frustración
Es evidente
reflexión cuando eres un soldado no
puedes pensar en las decisiones
políticas que toma nuestro gobierno
tenemos una misión y nuestro único
objetivo es esa misión no se pueden
mezclar estas cosas
solo quedaron unos pocos vehículos en la
base pronto desaparecerán y con ellos la
presencia del ejército francés en el
país